measures are not enough
only last week we saw energy bills going
up in the middle of a very real cost of
living crisis which is causing people
real hardship
all we've got today is a
cobbled together list of things that
could and should have been done over the
last 10 to 12 years
and it doesn't even tackle really
important things like insulating homes
which could save 400 pounds on
everybody's bill so it isn't enough it's
too little it's too late rising energy
costs obviously hit the forest in
society the hard is are you worried that
this won't do enough for that
this won't help those who only last
weeks or their energy bills go up by
hundreds of pounds what they want from
the government is a response that meets
that challenge
this list this cobbled together list of
things that could and should have been
done over the last 10 to 12 years isn't
enough
um and you know it leaves because of
political squabbling it leaves out of
account really important initiatives
like keeping homes warm insulating homes
which i've seen for myself can make a
huge difference and reduce bills by up
to 400 pounds that's the real action we
were looking for today obviously one of
the other aims of this policy is to
create energy security for the uk do you
think this achieves that well look
anything that makes us less reliant on
um importing our energy is a good thing
which is why
i didn't think the prime minister was
doing the right thing by saying we're
going to stop our alliance on russia but
then go to saudi arabia
but anything that keeps our supply in
britain is a good thing because we do
need a secure energy supply what would
labor actually be doing differently what
we've been calling for for a number of
years now is turbo on renewables
including onshore wind turbines
fast forwarding nuclear that should have
happened over the last decade and it
hasn't happened been a real failure
there
developing on hydrogen but also very
importantly insulating our homes so that
we reduce our energy intake and reduce
bills for people because at the moment
uh i think the thing that most people
are worried about is how on earth
they're going to pay their energy bills
and we need real answers to that
question right now
on a different subject we found out that
rishi tsunak's wife is non-domiciled in
her tax status she's getting a lot of
criticism for that but she's not
actually doing anything wrong is she
the the the chancellor has imposed
tax rise after tax rise on working
people and he said time and again
there's no alternative we've got no
option
if it now transpires that his wife has
used schemes to reduce her own tax then
that's breathtaking hypocrisy
and only goes to show it's more evidence
of just how out of touch this chancellor
is and i think he's got very very
serious questions to answer in relation
to these schemes what would you like to
see
him
um his wife the government do about this
a chancellor
who says to the british public that he
will tax them he's introduced 15 tax
rises
and he says all of this is necessary
there's no option
if it now transpires that his wife has
been using schemes to reduce her own tax
then i'm afraid that is breathtaking
hypocrisy
and
it shows yet again that we've got a
chancellor who is completely out of
touch with the struggles that so many
people in this country are going through
at the moment with this cost of living
crisis and he has very very serious
questions to answer does he does she
need to change her tax status that is
the case we need complete transparency
on this um so that we can all understand
what scheme she may have been using to
reduce her own tax but to use a scheme
when the chancellor is out there day
after day saying we need tax rises or
millions of people in this country who
are really really struggling is
breathtaking hypocrisy